- [Mark] Alright Maria.
Maria, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from LA.
- South central?
- South central, yeah.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood,
you had both of your parents growing up?
- No, just one.
- [Mark] Just mom?
- Just my mom, my mom from
when I was born up to seven.
And with her, she used to,
reason why I got taken from her is because
she's been out there with
multiple mans and having sex.
She'd get high next to the bed next to me.
She would say she going to grocery store
and she coming back,
would be gone for a week.
And it was, I was seven
and my brother was five.
She would leave us in there for like days.
So one particular day, my grandma
just happened to come
by and she wasn't there
and I opened the door and
she took us from there.
For us birthdays and stuff,
she would take us shopping
and buy birthday gifts,
you know, buy them.
And then we would come home
from school, they were all gone.
And then the men that she would be seeing,
actually two of them raped me,
when I was like more, let's
say more middle school
and then more high school.
And then like, as I got older too, as well
it was one Mexican, she
had one Hispanic guy
and when one was black.
It was in Long Beach, and I think,
Long Beach and Compton.
He had raped me and I told
her and she didn't believe me.
And so from there I was very,
it was just a multiple abuses.
And then I went from group
homes, multiple group homes.
And from the group homes,
when I left from there
I got out and I had one son,
and then with her jealousy
and her controlling me,
He ended up being taken from me,
not knowing how to be a mother as well.
When they took him, I
had some friends say,
hey, let's go, you dance pretty well.
Let's try, you can go from
different state to state.
So I tried it, I went from St. Louis.
That's where they kept
me hostage in St. Louis.
I went from Arizona and
from Arizona on to New York.
And then we got to St. Louis.
- [Mark] So you were
traveling around as a,
as a stripper?
- I was supposed to be dancing, you know,
young minded did not know.
- When you say dancing,
what do you mean?
- We stripping, dancing.
- Stripping, okay.
- at 23, I'm not knowing why.
So I go and when I get there,
it was like an apartment.
And they kept me barricaded
inside the back room.
And cutting up drugs,
whatever they were doing.
And I asked, I just got them frustrated.
I was there like over two months
and I happened to just come
out to use the restroom
and see an address, and
they had a home phone there
and I called and just told
them that I was there.
And they came by and they
came by one particular day,
for some reason, it must have been God.
They came by and they had just left
and came by and opened the door
and they took me and put
me back on the train.
I got back here.
When I got back here at Figeroua, Central.
Imperial and Figeroua.
Imperial and Figeroua and they said,
we want to hit the Primo,
I said, sure and I tried it.
And after smoking the Primo,
it started making me throw up.
But it would change real feelings,
then she said, just try
to pipe it's more better.
So I tried it, and from there,
I kind of like into it.
So being homeless, I stayed in a basement,
in a bus stop, a train.
I stayed in someone's building
on the top floor all the way,
if you go to the top floor
where they have like different levels
I went all the way to the fifth floor.
I stayed up in the top floor up there
and laid there for a while.
Went to a tent, just
kinda like not used to it.
I stayed in the tent where
roaches crawled around a lot.
It rained, it had holes in it.
I woke up with all kind of wet clothes.
And then, then I had back seizures.
And it woke up and a guy had
already took my clothes off
and he was trying to insert
his penis inside of me.
And then I kinda like
pushed him off or whatever.
And he was just staring,
so I pushed him off.
I was able to get away from that.
Then went back to Imperial Figeroua.
I was standing right
there, trying to figure out
how I was gonna survive.
I actually didn't, I didn't
get in a car with a man.
And he said, he'll take me, pay me.
It was the Bronco, Bronco Motel
went there and he said
he's going to pay me.
And he said, you want to
see where this stuff is?
Well, then after he did that
he turned me and pushed me down,
held me by the back of my neck
and raped me in from behind in my butt.
And I just been on the streets homeless,
If I was hungry, I would go in the store
Act like I'm buying something and grab it
and go sit in a restroom and eat.
If I saw something sitting by a trashcan
I would just eat it.
If I saw somebody's
stuff sitting down there.
I'd just pick it up and
eat it and stuff like that.
And so that's going on and on and on.
Shower, bathing was very, very hard.
I didn't have no where
to bathe, take a shower
and nothing like that.
Didn't have any clothes.
And then the mans down here say,
oh, well, you know I got
a place where it's cool.
And then it didn't turn
out to be what they said.
And then they said, would
you like a cigarette
or something to drink?
And I drank it and I wasn't able to walk.
when I woke up I was on the sidewalk,
with just an empty purse,
laying on the sidewalk.
With all of my belongings
I had some semen all between my legs.
And from that point on, I just,
I couldn't do it no more.
So here I will go up
to, travel all the way
to Alameda where the fashion district
and go right behind a trashcan
and lay behind there and sleep.
But then I learned that
it was transvestites
or they're homosexuals.
But they pretty much didn't bother me
but they had jumped me
and come through there to smoke crystal.
And one guy was trying to talk to me
and didn't want to talk to
him and I was very scared
and then he started
burning me with a pipe.
It burnt, but probably
have bruises on there
I was just in the corner from there.
So from that point on,
it was just like very
it was nowhere to turn to.
As the same as now.
but I'm trying to find myself,
but it's it's really hard
when you don't have anybody to help.
It's like they say, they'll help you.
They'll help you just, okay
let me get into contact with my boss.
And it's like, really, really not that.
And when you ask him
for help and they say,
okay, well, we'll get back to you.
We'll get back to you, get back to you.
Somebody burned down the tent I had.
I have no clothes, no food.
So on a daily basis, eating food
I just see if I hear
people come with food.
If they don't come by with food,
I would just ask and ask.
If not, if I saw
something that's too much,
I would eat it because I was super hungry.
Those port-a-pottys and the
urinals, the restrooms there
sometimes I would just
stay in there all night
praying that nobody would
bother me because it was cold.
I was hungry with no
shoes on, no underwear on,
you know, like how I feel now.
I want to take a shower
so bad and eat something
and I don't have it.
And it just, it's just discomfort.
And then the men, the men right here say
you wanna come with me,
you wanna come with me?
I'll give you five dollars.
And I'm just like very scared of men, now.
I hate them.
The bruise right here, a guy
told me to come with him.
He busted me in the head right here.
It was busted wide open right here.
And it kind of like, it's
kind of like healing now.
And then from here, my shoulder.
Someone knock my shoulder out of place.
And in my eye, I'm losing my vision
by going with one of them
and leaving with them
And he gets you inside of a tent
and then they start hurting,
beating you from that point on.
So it's like now,
for me, it's like, I guess,
It's like I don't have anyone.
- [Mark] How long have you
been living on the street?
- Since I was 19.
- And how old are you now?
- I'm 44.
- And you have one child?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And where's, where's your son?
- He is not with me.
He's way in, I would say Inglewood.
And I would love to speak
with him and talk to him.
And the crazy thing about it is
I just happened to went on Facebook.
To just, to see how he's doing.
He's now 27 and he's
a beautiful young man.
But I don't know how to approach him
because he was, he's been gone
since he was four months from me.
And so I don't know how to
approach him or to speak to him.
But I don't, not saying
I feel bad, I want to
talk to him, but I don't.
Cause I want to come to,
I want to talk to him as, you know,
a normal civilized person.
But I just don't think
that being like this
is civilized to approach him.
I don't want to bring no more pain to him
and trauma in his life by
coming to him in this situation.
I'd rather come to him and explain to him
everything I did to him was for the best.
I want to be a mom in a better way.
But coming to him like this
doesn't make it no better.
You know, cause ever since,
when it happened to him, he was gone
trying out different drugs.
I just seem to, was
leaning towards the drug,
but it was not really towards the drug.
Cause if you realize it,
the drugs have nothing to do with it.
Some people say the drug got them down.
But technically it's mental.
Mentally things in the mind
that is like really going on.
You can, you can get sober.
But those things like they haunt you.
Like if you were as a
hunter hunting a deer
and you hunt for deer
and that's just something
you do every season.
Well, mine was just
like an off an on thing.
And it's like, you could talk to someone,
but it's like it doesn't solve the problem
because it's like it hits you hard.
It hits you really, really hard.
Because coming from a background
as a having a family
that was not like bad.
And then coming from a mother
and seeing, I'm watching
her do all the things
that I see here.
You would think I knew better
than to go down this path
because I'm watching
what went down with her.
You would think, hey,
that's a sample right there.
Hey, you don't want to choose that path.
You see what it done to your mom.
And it's like, now I'm doing it.
So it didn't, it didn't really sat.
One day my mom, last year,
someone told her I was down here
and she got on Facebook
and tried to talk to me
and come to be with me.
I don't want to talk to her
because you chose, you
chose a man over me.
You know, all these things,
And you talking about coming
back and being with you.
And it's like, it's just
scary, it's really very scary
when you don't trust your own mom.
I'd rather, until I
feel like in my own self
I'd rather be behind the
trash can and sleep somewhere
where I know somebody's
not going to hurt me.
But now, over here, it's
getting beyond that point.
Now you can't really like lay
some where and sleep anywhere.
because you know, I woke up
on the sidewalk last week.
I was on Fourth and
Los Angeles laying down
and it woke up and it was in the daytime
and I woke up and his
man was on top of me.
But I was laying flat and
he jumped on him from behind
and start kissing me and I'm screaming,
hey, get off me, hey, get off me.
And people just kept walking past
walking past, walking past.
Like they didn't see me
screaming and yelling.
Telling him, hey get the hell off me.
And he goes, oh, sorry.
I thought you was my
wife and kept laughing.
And then it's like in the broad daylight,
this is not night.
Your businesses are open
people walking past.
And it's like, you don't exist.
And it, and then I see the same man, again
four or five days, he walk
past me and just kept smiling.
And then I just went and
had a little hood on me
and I crossed over
and went on the opposite
side of the street.
So now it's like, what do
you, what do I do for now?
What honestly, what do I do?
- [Mark] What is the hardest
part for you right now?
Is it just the lack of hope?
- Hope, courage, self esteem.
Because I don't believe in myself anymore.
I once upon a time, I
did believe in myself
but now I don't believe in myself.
I don't love myself.
I don't feel like, attractive, a woman.
I don't, I don't feel,
I feel like this small.
Now it's like, it's beyond that point.
I guess if I don't believe in myself,
no courage, no hope.
I don't think I'm going to make it.
I wish I could,
but I feel like,
I feel like they're going
to do the same thing
that has been done to me
from childhood from here
into a different state.
And it's just, I'm just very scared.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends?
- The friends that I
thought were my friends.
No, they're not my friends.
Because when you go to them and they say,
oh, my boyfriend's here or I'm doing this.
But a real, actually friend.
I don't know what that's like to have,
a friend, never had that.
The only one was my
brother and he's in heaven.
And he was young when we were growing up.
So considered as a friend? No.
Just like the gentlemen I seen around,
I saw outside right here.
They think, I don't know, but I know.
And I know what they do to other people.
And they stand around and stuff like that
standing around when this
place, I guess it's not open.
They stand outside, you know,
humiliating, intimidating women,
pushing up on women, or using them.
I see all that, that's
why I keep my distance.
And then, the other day, they
ask me what you brought me?
They'd say, you going to be
okay, you going to be okay?
I don't even trust them out there.
- [Mark] What is your drug today?
What drug are you using?
- Well, I was using crack cocaine
and I tried some some
crystal of some Sherm.
And it's like, why are you trying it?
It's just, I feel
I wanted to die.
I didn't want to be here.
So I was like, I don't, I'm not
I don't even have the
courage to kill myself.
I said, I want to commit suicide.
I can't commit suicide
because I don't have the
courage to just actually do it.
So you take a drug that
would take you out?
I now learned that two friends,
I mean, they're not friends,
but young ladies that used to speak to me.
They're dead.
One died in a tent, was
dead in there for two days.
Went in there with a man.
And the other went to a
hotel with a gentleman
and she got her throat slashed.
So that, I'm guessing is an eye opener.
I'm not too sure.
I wouldn't say because it's the
we're all down the same road.
So I'm guessing that's what it is
because all that right here
and I don't understand,
downtown LA, they say
they're here to help you,
but they watch you get beat.
They watch you get raped.
They watch you and just keep
going and just keep going.
And only time you actually get help
is if you flag them down but
they feel like you're on drugs
and you're down here, so
it's just a drug situation.
Oh, she just high or
they high or something.
And they literally keep going.
Because when that guy did that to me
and I went and find someone, they said,
well was he on drugs, or was he like this?
We'll keep an eye and drive around
and see if we can find him.
It was like, oh, you know like
brush you off to the side.
Like, whatever.
But literally it wasn't,
it was on a street called Omar and Fourth.
And he did it and there was
people standing right there
There's like, most people
say, hey, you know, stop.
They was like, well, what happened?
And then after I was laying
with my nose bleeding
and I couldn't see,
did anyone walk over and say are you okay?
So the off and on drug thing.
But it's not the drug thing.
It's more of here your life.
And it's surviving.
Making them hungry, thirsty.
- [Mark] How are you
supporting yourself now?
- I was around here moving around.
I used to be, I was still
trying to prostitute
but I don't even, I can't prostitute
because when you get with someone,
it's not what they say or they say that
and they may hand some money
and turn around and rape you and beat you
and take it back from you.
Then you going back all over the day.
And it's like, every day
you got to figure out
how you going to eat and drink water.
And so mostly because people out there,
basically it's in a tent said, hey,
and she didn't know my name,
she said, hey lady, lady,
you want some water?
You want something to drink?
I said, yeah, but when it
went to use the restroom,
no it's a port-a-potty, come back,
someone's on crystal, they
burned it down the tent
that the lady had gave me.
So now I'm basically one
blanket and I'm laying
on the side on the corner,
but I won't lay over here.
Like I go way past, past
past the Greyhound station, all past,
past Mateo over when you go
up by a LA river under there.
Make sure nobody's around.
I sit there for a couple hours, make sure,
and then I'll lay there and fall asleep.
And then just figure out
how to take a shower.
It's like, it's not going to happen.
And so not only that,
this corona thing here,
now it's like triple hard.
You can't bathe, you have panties.
And it's, you know, it's hard.
It's, it's really, really
hard to walk around.
You used to be able to go to the missions
and say are you serving food here?
And now it's like, we're not
serving at a certain time.
Or if you don't have a mask
on you can't come in and eat.
And I don't have a mask or any of that.
So I'm standing there like,
I want something to eat
but I'm not going to stand around
because all the commotion is going on.
And I'm like, right here,
this is healing right here.
Starting to get better right here.
I say I was being beat like that.
My leg's still swollen, my ankles
but it's getting all better.
But you know, it's like
first you going to do this in there.
But yeah, it's hard.
- [Mark] Yeah. Sounds terrible.
What's what's the worst
thing that's happened
to you down here?
You've been down here a long time.
- Bbeing raped, being
raped in broad daylight.
And they snatch your
purse and your money bag
and people standing around
and just keep passing
by and hear you scream.
And you don't know if
you're going to make it.
It had kind of had me still
traumatized a little bit.
I don't know.
And after that, being drugged.
After going through this healing and say,
stop and say, he can I
get you a cigarette, sure,
and it's not a cigarette.
And I can't walk.
And then the man keep
pulling my pants down.
And I keep saying, stop.
He keep pulling my pants down.
I keep saying stop.
And he trying to go up in my shirt
and he grabbed me and I said,
hey, can you stop touching me?
Stop touching me, stop touching me,
please stop touching me.
And then I'm looking at him doing this
And I'm like he's gonna take a knife out.
And I'm sitting there, but I can't move
because whatever you call it,
I think sherm or something
I can't move, and it's like
a very scary situation,
very situation.
So you try to like say,
okay, I'm gonna compromise
let's see just what
this person going to do.
Then I said, okay, well, okay.
Okay, okay, I'll do it, I'll do it.
I'll do it, cause I don't want no problem.
I'll do it, okay.
And then he says, okay, you know what,
let me get up and go get another
cover out of the cupboard.
And then somebody, a
guy happened to walk by
and say, you okay?
And I said, no, he's
trying to do something.
He said let me help you up
and tell the dude back off of her.
That's the only way because if he didn't,
I think he, he would've kept
proceeding to do what he wanted to do me.
So yeah.
Being dirty or your cycle, period,
you gotta stuff tissue in your panties.
Cause you have no tampons and put on.
As now I'm using, I'm using
paper towel between my legs.
Well, because I don't know
what women sitting there,
and this is very embarrassing
to me, as a woman to say,
you got find a paper towel on the ground
and stick between your legs,
cause you bleeding really, really bad.
And you have no tampon as a
woman, but where do I turn to?
Where do I go?
That's going to do nothing.
I learned that it's about drugs.
And I learned things about drugs themself.
I want to get help so bad
I want to be up the streets
or women's shelter, whatever.
Whatever somebody helped me with.
I just don't want to be on this,
I don't know, but I
mean, you can't be picky
with somebody helping you out.
You just have to be more cautious.
But man, I just want to be able
to get inside somewhere safe.
- [Mark] I'll set you up
for at least a place to stay
and some food and maybe
we can get you somewhere.
- Yeah, cause you just get scared.
- [Mark] You know, a women's
shelter or something like that.
Have you been to some of
the shelters for, for women?
- I've never been into,
into the women's shelter.
I see them.
And then when I asked
some lady, she say, okay
well they're helping people.
I don't know where to go.
Someone said, okay
since you have epilepsy,
severe brain trauma, they starting out
helping people like.
And then later, okay, well
where are you going to be?
I'm going to come back.
And she haven't came back since.
And I really don't want to be out there
because I'm very scared.
- [Mark] All right.
Well we'll try again.